if this is what multiplication is what
would you think division looks like
division is just the inverse of
multiplication right so you should
expect that they things it work in the
same way what would you guess yes okay
so if I'm doing the inverse of this over
here
that's division right then it makes
sense that I would do the inverse of
this long vacation will also become
divisions and the inverse of addition is
subtraction right so I'm gonna get
something that looks like this and
here's the wonderful thing and I'll just
leave it to you if you are the curious
type right how did we arrive at this how
did we get from that to this and the
answer was we just multiply the thing
out right we expended it with a whole
bunch of cosine terms and then we used
our trig identities at tree expansions
right well you're gonna have some more
expansions coming up in here and you can
do it in exactly the same process but it
looks very similar honestly with just a
third classes of minuses different as
you'd expect so I'm gonna leave that for
your homework if you like that's a great
question okay let's just um let's think
about that for a second ah - if r2 is 0
okay now hold on a second we don't need
to think too much about this actually we
know exactly the number that is where r2
is 0 right it's the origin right it's
that one number where once you know what
the modulus is you don't care what the
argue is anymore because it's like what
doesn't matter what you're facing you're
at the origin so right so that means if
I choose 0 then in fact the number
itself is 0 ok now we know what
multiplication by zero means you've got
to scale it down
okay that works exactly the same way
what happens when you divide you can't
define it meaning do it right for this
reason if you say if you say six over
two equals three right
the reason you can say it is because you
can say 64 was three times two that's
why it makes sense okay but if you go
six over zero equals something then no
matter what you put over here no matter
how you define it right then by
definition you should be able to say
that 6 is zero at times that's something
but there's no things you can multiply
by zero so she get six or five or any
other nor than zero number so this is
why it's not the mathematicians are lazy
it's that you can't define it with
anything no matter what you put me here
you will break these okay okay excellent
any questions on that first one more
implication question okay one more
application and then we'll work through
some examples together okay I want you
to think that again in all of this one
odd form right and I want you to tell me
what you can say about this guy mmm
think carefully
think carefully so this is conjugate
right in Cartesian form we know that if
Z equals x plus iy then what do you how
do we define the conjugate yeah that's
right this plus will turn into a minus
right
Thanks - I want now what is that going
to me in Morag form well let me give you
the easy part okay if I'm defining it
this is just not say one sentence just
says so we're just going R and okay I
have a look at this double right well
this pair of numbers rather what's going
to happen to the modules how is it going
to change from one number to the next
they actually it's not going to change
is it okay so for example if I put on
two here let's put X plus iy there where
is X minus iy whether the real number is
still saved so horizontally still
incitements but I look
reflected across the real access rights
and here I am at X minus iy right so the
modulus is still unchanged it's just
gonna be off but my angle is changed me
right clearly my angle has changed in
order to get this first number I go up
like that this video how do I get to the
second number how do I get to the
country again - yeah you don't go up you
go yeah or I should say rather than
going into clockwise I go and this is
one of the reasons why it's like Oh what
are many reasons why the principal
argument is not naught to 2pi right it's
not a lot to do pi I mean we could
define it like that if we wanted to but
it makes so much more sense to say will
if I have conjugates going around you i
think a one direction or your the
opposite one but that makes it much
easier so what you've got here is going
to me cause on negative theta is mine
here's my real putt okay now it's worth
noticing hold on a second
we just said that the real part doesn't
change right like look there your plots
do the same so why am i changed my feet
off because constant even function that
causes an even function positive
negative ena is cos theta plus I sine
okay you clearly see by the way look I
this is looking for a pie in fact it's
almost going in Reverse because cos of
negative theta is just cos theta is an
even function
what outside here signs an odd function
right so this is minus I sine theta oh
yeah look there it is there's the
conjugate right instead of cos theta
plus I sine theta there's my negative
right
but he's the power of I can think of it
exclusively in terms of how the argument
has changed now that how the two bits of
cherries okay